we begin in China where the fate of this
man has prompted a diplomatic rebuke a
clarification and then disbelief
this is Weger singer abdul rahim hate
after reports emerged of his death in a
chinese interned internment camp this
video was released today it's February
the 10th 2019 I'm in the process of
being investigated for allegedly
violating the national laws I'm now in
good health and have never been abused
now the video purports to show hate
alive but in prison prisons that have
sprung up across Northwest China housing
more than a million Muslims in what
China has called re-education camps
reports of the death of hate however
prompted for the first time a rebuke
from a majority Muslim nation Turkey it
called the reintroduction of internment
camps in the 21st century a great shame
for Humanity and asked China to close
the internment camps here is how the
Chinese government responded the Turkish
Foreign Ministry spokesperson statement
said the famous Weger folk musician hey
yet died in prison while serving his
second year of sentence but I saw his
video online yesterday showing that he
is not only alive but also very healthy
London is Rehema Mehmood she's a singer
and human rights activist his mood thank
you so much for speaking to us I just
have to ask you at the outset do you
still believe that abdul rahim yet is
still alive thank you for having me i
would like to believe that he is alive
but the video that china has put raises
a lot of questions for example there are
no details about where he is held which
prison he is in and also from the
contents of what he said it sounded as
if he was forced to repeat what he was
told
he said on the video that case in good
health but we can see that the video on
the video he looked 10 years at least 10
years older than he did before but this
follows a similar pattern that China has
employed in the past in which people
who've been accused of crimes against
the state or whom the state is
investigating suddenly appear in terms
of a video confession confessing to
their crimes or making some such claims
yes this is a very common common act
that China or Chinese government also
forced the the prisoners to do or to say
what they are what they are forced to do
what are the crimes that abdur-rahim hey
it is in prison for he has no crime but
according to his close friend he was
arrested in April 2017 because of one of
the songs that he sang and called uttal
our fathers the poet of the regime
Abdullah who wrote the lyrics was also
arrested at that time and there was one
phrase in anybody's jungler - it is
martyrs of who was misinterpreted by the
Chinese government as being a call for
jihad the actual song was about
remembering the brave fathers who fought
a horse pecked to protect their country
and people and criticizing the young men
of today who lacked responsibility and
only like partying but this was taken
this was taken against our dream age now
the Turkish government has asked for the
camps in Xinjiang to be closed down do
you think that this will have an impact
on the Chinese government first of all
we are very happy at least the Turkish
government at last speak up against
these terrible atrocities what is
happening - we were people but I doubt
it
giving how the Chinese government always
act to gain their own way but I do hope
that that will take some effect now the
United Nations and other Human Rights
bodies have also criticized these
internment camps that China calls
reeducation camps in Xinjiang but these
camps continue to exist do you think
that the international community has
failed the weekers of China yes I can
say so because they the government the
Chinese government not only closed not
not closed the camps but expanding it
continuously and they have they're still
arresting more and more people and the
innocent people into these camps and
going through indoctrinated programs and
that people are dying and being tortured
in these camps but the international
community not really acting or doing
enough to stop or to stop this these
camps Chinese government clearly
committing crime against humanity and
the international community I believe
should you do more to stop this what
rain I'm a mood singer and human rights
activist joining us from London thank
you very much speaking to us
you